[Music]
could you just explain
the difference between hot boredom and
cold boredom or the spectrum of boredom
yeah yeah so hot boredom and cold
boredom is really great framing to to
think about
we don't really do this so much anymore
but imagine you're online at the post
office or online at the dmv
and it's just an interminably long line
and you got to be someplace else
and
there's nothing to distract you
and that discomfort that's hot boredom
that's like it's literally my body
starts to feel achy and all that stuff
but
contrast it to cold boredom
and i know you've done meditation
retreats imagine
not the first three or four days of
meditation retreat which often provokes
hot boredom
right what the hell am i doing here i
gotta i can't even sleep it's enough
but by the day four day five day seven
day ten
you're sitting there and literally
there's nothing dramatic
going on in your mind
there's no drama
and you're okay
and
all of a sudden you catch a glimpse of a
bird that's really interesting
that's called boredom
and i would argue that the mind
needs cold boredom
it needs those days of
simple
you know my therapist calls it just
simple stirring the oatmeal kind of
morning here i am do do just turn the
oatmeal
because that's a moment of rest from
which we can then
go about the rest of our time the rest
of our day
i have many questions
as one would expect if i invited you on
the podcast to talk about this
let's start with
a hypothetical situation so i i can and
i'll tell you something that i haven't
talked about much
maybe not at all publicly but i've spent
the last i would say year
sitting with a lot of void very
deliberately not committing to any big
projects and it has been
one of the most difficult
painful experiences of my life
and
i threw every tool in my toolkit at it
meditating do it twice a day do it three
times a day take two weeks in the in the
wilderness i threw everything i had at
it and ultimately decided
sitting with this void for this long is
actually not good for my mental health
and
i still haven't
prematurely committed to something huge
just to commit but
i got to a point where
sitting with that void
felt unhealthy
and so my my question to you and i'm not
i'm not at the point of total burnout
but if if you're talking to a client
who
like it or not is not going to
get to a place of comfortable cold
boredom before they burn out
and
you jointly decide or or he or she
decides they're going to take a
sabbatical so they have yet to become
sort of comfortable stirring the oatmeal
but they're going to take a sabbatical
what advice do you give to that person
um start small start with tiny steps
you know um when you're talking baby
steps out of the obvious yeah
how about starting with a weekend
how about starting with one evening you
know i mean literally
you were
you asked me before about the
when i started
sabbaticalizing
and um it it feels so long ago and it
feels so natural to me that i actually
forgot
what really began this
and it was something that you said where
you talked about going going off into a
jungle going into a forest and something
for for the 10 years previous to me
taking two months sabbatical
i would take
monumental off the grid trips why were
they monumental because that was the
only way i could really break
being attached to the grid
because if you go to as i did you know
across the polar ice cap in greenland
for some reason you don't get a good
sell signal it's like it's amazing
um
you you are force or you know i went
rafting the futulafu river in in the
chilean patagonian
area and there really isn't a good wi-fi
signal and it's beautiful
and so those small little steps i i have
a client i just started with in
september
and he's taking his first vacation
two weeks in namibia
first vacation in 10 years
first vacation in 10 years
it was only because his life partner
recently sold her business
and that they
have they feel like they have the time
that's not healthy
and uh so so practical advice start
small
start where you are start with
a day you know our mutual friend brad
feld was the first person i know
who used the notion of digital sabbath
right i'm going to turn off the devices
from friday till sunday night
and just
i'm just not available and train the
people in my life to know that that is
happening
just start just start there
just start there
you